it happens naturally yeah you know what
I mean like it's got you know it will
happen naturally I don't believe it
should it be false and you can't plan
these things and the relationships is a
tricky one it should happen naturally
and like I said should flow you know so
yeah what do you guys think that you
need to bring to the table in order to
be a long-term 20-year girlfriend or
wife and is there a difference
um I think
stability
if you know you're stable within
yourself mentally financially
every Lee then then I feel like that's
all that matters and likewise for the
man if he's stable enough to be in a
relationship and to accommodate that
financially mentally physically whatever
way emotionally then that's that's what
so do you mean when you say stability
like financially stable yeah as a girl
you should be financially stable okay
don't don't just append everything on
the man you know don't expect because
when you expect things you could let get
let get let down sorry
I agree with that okay yeah go ahead
definitely in a relationship
um you also need to have your own funds
behind you you can't rely on a man
because then what happens if that man
leaves then if you're left with nothing
men don't leave
they always come back that's true no no
fun fact one percent of the time do you
think that women divorce or that men
divorce women I think a lot of the time
it is women that leave a thousand
percent what percent of the time do you
think women leave
maybe like 80 of the time yeah that's
true I think they're just when they're
everywhere 70 to 80 yeah and what
percent if you're college educated
there's only a 10 chance you're gonna
get left yeah I do think as well like a
stable stable relationship you know
bringing stuff to the table I think you
need to just like have have your
priorities in check you know again like
be stable financially physically
um be healthy and cheap yeah so fat
people shouldn't find Love Of course
they should
most definitely
you don't have to be in being you don't
have to be in shape
as well as wealth you know if someone is
like really severely overweight and
there's some people that are too
severely overweight people when they're
in love and like they don't they don't
do anything about their health how long
are they going to live for oh my God
my dad told me not to date fat people
because he said you have to take care of
them later
you're gonna be yeah
is like a serious issue so you should be
in shape you should bring that to it's
okay that's okay
I'm just I'm trying
I'm trying to list
yeah I think you should you should look
after yourself I think you know like
it's important to care for yourself and
look after yourself you know a lot of
the time like when people are like
really severely overweight and like
obese and stuff it's because they're not
looking after themselves
okay so it's harsh people call me fat
foaming yeah but like yeah
that's okay yeah we hate we hate cat
phobia here yeah we don't stand for fat
phobia at all yeah like I'm not against
fat people
I used to be fat guys but at the same
time like I'm afraid I'm afraid of fat
people really yeah I'm scared of them is
that phobic what
I'm afraid of them
terrified
hey I'm prep I'm yeah I'm like
transphobic too I'm all the focused
I did not know that existed yeah yeah um
if you call someone fat they'll
literally
no it's not like I think the whole body
positivity movement is really important
but at the same time if you're severely
overweight people like it's your health
at the end of the day normalizes obesity
I think it does I think it does and it's
not it's not a good thing because your
lifespan is going to be shortened
because you you don't look after
yourself some people are overweight
because of health conditions and like
certain medications and stuff but that
is a very small minority of people so
um back to the we need stability and
In-Shape anything else Financial
stability stability I think stability
also mentally is really important
obviously you can go through blips of
your mental health like during a
relationship and your partner should
support you vice versa but um yeah to be
in like a healthy relationship I think
like your mental health is something
that you need to prioritize
um anything what should women bring to
the team
[Music]
um
what should women bring to the table
themselves because every woman is
different so you should know in general
in general yeah in general
yeah
your true self of who you really are
exactly in general that's true but if
you're a loser yeah what is your
definition of a loser coming back to
what I'm about to say Do not compare me
to the next woman or the woman coming
after me because I am different there's
only one you yeah
I have to offer so throughout my 22
years okay so what do you have to offer
from your 22 years that's a lot we're
going to be here all day so we'll come
back to that
it's hot
she brings a lot to tables for the rest
of them okay okay
just give me three cool three things
knowledge wisdom and understanding
period done
okay okay
go ahead you know what same here like I
said I bring a little table but I'm
gonna be a bit more specific
freakiness is very important okay a
freakiness all right I would say but
yeah no um we're actually being serious
obviously yeah I'm serious about that
but I'm actually being serious
um it would be
um my mindset I think I've got a really
like good elevated type of mindset and I
think that what do you what do you mean
by Alex no elevating no no no no no as
in like motivation like my energy that
I'm quite I have like a good drive and a
motivation I'm quite positive optimistic
so the people around me and in my circle
can feed off my energy and they can all
win in life that's what I'm here so you
have you have high energy and you're
driven that's what I mean by like okay
my t-shirt okay yeah so I'm just I'm
trying to write this down okay yeah it's
really anything else I would say
um
I'm good at everything
women of many talents
okay can we can we name one okay
oh obviously we want to know I can sing
dance act sing dance act um um I'm smart
as well I'm good at balancing stuff I'm
not balanced up on my head I mean
multitasking yeah multitasking I can
balance a lot I can't do that
yeah like okay for example I'll take
example for a long time obviously when I
was I was 19 so obviously last year I
just finished sixth form but throughout
my I started doing for music when I was
like 16 actually that started to me when
I was 16 17 18 but throughout that
process I was still in full-time
education so it was hard to obviously
balance like I'll do like a sold out
show with like and have like my manager
and like see Biz there and then I have
to be dragged onto like a table and
being told it was hard balancing what
all I wanted to do was fly so again
balancing is important and I still got
the Grays on white by end of it so yeah
well done yes okay
we'll give you okay okay so I'm just
gonna read back to what what you guys
said if there's anything you think that
there should be added just let me know
okay being financially stable in shape
mentally stable
um I wrote themselves like knowing
yourself I think that was what I wrote
okay knowledge oh oh those you you bring
yourself
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness
um
driven high energy singing dancing
acting okay multitasking
talents and it's also you need to be
securing yourself as well you need to
love yourself that's the most important
thing
security self-love that's the most
important thing okay yeah okay can I add
something
um this is just my personal opinion by
the way I feel like having a source like
my my source is God my source is
spirituality my source is my intuition
so as long as you have a source then
that would yeah add to
oh no she means she means like a belief
guidance yeah yeah yeah like religion
yes that's true that's true not
necessarily not religion not religion
not religion not religion not religion
spiritual spirituality I believe in God
though okay so
stability Financial stability in shape
mentally stable bringing yourself
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing acting multitasking spirituality
secure yourself
my question
what my question was what do you think
that we women need to bring to the table
in order to be aware does this sound
like a traditional wife to you
anything I just read back to you does
that sound like a traditional way I
think maybe like a textbook
old-fashioned wife would be like you
know
um I think nurturing caring you know can
raise children can cook and clean
typical like wife like back in the day
caring so so why didn't we name any of
those things before because I think we
were kind of I don't know we already
know that point I was kind of balancing
like both men and women
listening these are not honesty like the
stuff you guys listed sounds like what
women want from a guy
women women and men aren't the same we
don't look for the same things like
women men don't want dudes big blessing
you want to date a girl that acts like a
dude yeah but the reason why the reason
why I didn't mention
[Music]
I've done this before it's not just you
guys blessing would you want to date a
girl does this like sound like wife
material financially stable in shape go
ahead and shave that's good mentally
stable
um them bringing themselves to the table
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing good at multitasking spiritual
secure and self-love that's the whole
package is there is there anything more
but you know what I was looking anyway
let him talk now say some of that stuff
but the majority team now what in
particular sorry I'm curious yeah what
did you like from that list
um I like the freakiness
I told you guys okay let's actually
breaking this let's actually hear no no
it's more we actually look for like
wifey material like nurturing
um yeah we don't need you to bring
anything to the table really to be
honest um so you go with anyone then
yeah he's not trim yeah yeah
being themselves like he's going for a
girl oh yeah we said trees yeah
themselves honest yeah in themselves um
now some of this stuff is a bit
pretentious like you think so yeah you
think spirituality is pretentious
depends what what kind of spirituality
is it actually you know what yeah I need
to hear your answer properly you guys
just let him speaking Yeah I think she's
a point of spirituality what what
spiritually is it well it depends for me
I believe that all everything is down to
one so I believe every God that they
serve and every religion is one God yeah
that's something to say I believe that
division is I don't know why there's
division in in religion but that's
that's up to them yeah but I feel like
everything all stems from or should stem
from love right love love is what war oh
yeah so would you date someone from any
religion then you would say yes I
actually would depending on their
mindset and how they perceive their
religion and how they believed like how
they understand their religion so
mindset it is mindset yeah I would how
would that work in your household
um as long as we can compromise and you
know make sure that all the good aspects
of the religion are being applied into
our relationship
then do you believe men men are the
leaders of the relationship yes I do so
if they say that my children are
Christian or they're Muslim are you
gonna go with that I'm gonna be fine
with it my mom was a Christian my dad's
a Muslim so I was brought up in a very
diverse religion I guess I don't know
but I came out to be spiritual you can
say submission is what we're looking for
yeah
he was looking for submission you you
are submissive woman because I feel like
a man wants to feel like a man
he wants to feel like a man so if
there's a woman and like she's wearing
the pants and she's taking complete
control he's not gonna feel very manly I
have a question if a guy said to you
take that off that's too revealing Are
You Gonna Change are you gonna argue
[Music]
[Laughter]
too bad
do you think that makes all of you toxic
because you just said you'd be okay with
submission but when he told you what to
do you're gonna argue I mean when it
comes to telling someone what to do like
telling me I can't wear a certain outfit
because it's too revealing like
I want to protect you it's like but the
thing is is he protecting me from other
men or is he insecure and not
comfortable with me going out because
other men are going to look at me
if you have a nice car as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible